this is the set behind me Christine
Brown giving sister wise fans a look at
her next chapter and I really just feel
like this is the path I'm supposed to be
on now and confirming she's part of the
next season after splitting with Cody
Brown I'm still doing Sister Wives no
worries everybody last year the exes
went their separate ways after more than
25 years together so for us plural
marriage doesn't work
for us marriage doesn't work with
Christine saying farewell to Arizona and
hello to Utah the love of living in Utah
close to my kids it's been fabulous and
now the reality star is sharing a
glimpse of the new Homestead on Tick
Tock it's my basement it's unfinished
it's super awesome it's like my favorite
room in the house the sneak peek comes
soon after Christine opened up about her
final day on the OG set this is the
couch
right here that I've sat on
for years talking about the show and
discussing my feelings this is the last
day I am on the set in Flagstaff
and it is a little Bittersweet I am
definitely not leaving Sister Wives this
is in fact the set in my home I'm so
excited yeah there were questions about
her future with the series post breakup
I'm excited about there's a hope for a
future but Christine reassures fans with
a tour of where she's filming the new
season here it is the set
so there we go it has unfinished walls
and
the producer sits right there and then
the cameraman sit back in that closet
right there
I made like a promise to like Cody and
everybody else and I will stay with
Sister Wives that's what our family's
been doing for so long I feel like it
would be disloyal if I you know decided
to not be part of the show as you can
see behind me this is where I sit
and it's like Way Forward like this is
where I sit the producer sits in this
lovely desk that he made behind me you
don't ever see what's ahead of the other
there but it's got all these really cool
book jackets it's beautiful I'm so
excited and coming up on Sister Wives
more drama for the famous family we've
been separated for several months what
following Christine's split two of
Cody's other partners Mary and Janelle
also parted ways with Cody so are you
separated yes we are separated leaving
the patriarch down to one wife Robert
who is the only one he is legally
married to do you think if Christine
didn't object that Mary and Cody would
have gotten back together uh yeah
because when Cody says and thinks that
type of stuff it usually happens
that's a lie that's not me and I would
never do that so no one knows exactly
what season 18 will look like I like my
life so much better now but for now fans
can tell Christine's happy with the
change in scenery I thought you'd like a
little bit of a sneak peek mwah
[Music]